There is an absolutely insane, criminal, disgusting,
immoral and depraved series of allegations
against Donald Trump and his family, which
are completely unsurprising if you've been
paying attention for the last four to five
years.
A Business Insider exclusive investigation
has revealed that Donald Trump's son in law,
Jared Kushner, helped to create a Trump campaign
Shell Corporation, which secretly paid Trump's
family and spent on their behalf one hundred
and seventy million dollars in campaign reelection
money.
It actually spent more than that in total.
But at issue are about one hundred and seventy
million dollars.
Six hundred and seventeen million dollars
is the total amount in play here.
Now, we had rumblings about this story months
ago.
I've been covering this story for months.
You all seemed very interested in it.
The number of emails I got about it was huge.
I did a story back in July called Trump Campaign
Laundering Millions to his own family in September.
The investigations into this were heating
up and I covered it in a segment called Trump,
panicking and accused of laundering one hundred
and seventy million dollars.
This is all part of the same scam about which
we now have more specific information.
So listen to these details which are being
presented by a source familiar with this operation
to Business Insider.
The way this scam worked is that Jared Kushner,
who is Trump's son in law and also a White
House senior adviser, if you can believe that,
directed his sister, his his sister in law,
Trump's daughter in law, Laura Trump.
That's Eric Trump's wife.
Got to keep all of it straight.
Jared Kushner directs Laura Trump and Mike
Mike Pence, his nephew John Pence, and Trump
campaign CFO Sean Dollman to be on the board
of this shell company that they created.
The company is called American Made Media
Consultants Corporation and American Made
Media Consultants LLC.
Now, that should ring a bell because this
is related to the name of Donald Trump's former
campaign manager, Brad Parr Scales Company.
And what they did is they spent in total six
hundred and seventeen million dollars.
That's about half of the one point to six
billion that Trump's campaign fund raised
and some of the spending was legitimate.
So the issue is not the six hundred and seventeen
million.
The issue is that about one hundred and seventy
million of that money is essentially laundered
money as salaries to Trump's family and others,
as well as a slush fund of all sorts of spending.
Why did they do this?
The reason they did this?
Is believed to be to avoid Trump's donors
finding out that a whole bunch of their money
is actually just being funneled back out to
Trump's family and friends.
The next step is that if the Department of
Justice finds that this was done knowingly
and willfully, they would open up an investigation.
But the big bombshell is that several sources
from the Justice Department and FEC told The
Business Insider that there are investigators
that may already be looking into the campaign's
activity.
So there's a few different things to talk
about here.
Number one, is anybody surprised to hear this?
If you've been paying attention, you couldn't
possibly be surprised about this.
Number two, I don't actually know that Trump's
donors would really care if they knew about
this.
And what I mean by that is Larra Trump was
getting one hundred and eighty thousand a
year.
You know, a whole bunch of people were getting
one hundred and eighty grand a year.
And all this all this money was being laundered
into companies held by Trump's family and
friends.
If you went with this information to a lot
of Trump's followers, I don't think they'd
be mad.
You would say to them, aren't aren't you upset
that for every hundred bucks you donated,
50 was funneled to this company and then a
bunch of that was funneled to Trump's family
just for going around and doing interviews
and not not really doing much?
And I think most of them would say, no, Trump
has a great family and they're all helping
him win.
And I'm happy.
The point is, I think a lot of Trump's donors
would rationalize this money being laundered
anyway.
Now, number three, here's something disgustingly
ironic.
The defense bill that Donald Trump wants to
veto for ridiculous reasons also contains
a crackdown on the use of shell companies
to launder money.
It's just like a side note.
That's number three.
And then number four, pardons.
You know how we've been talking about is Trump
going to preemptively pardon his family members,
Gerardi, Ivonka, whoever?
We weren't sure why Trump would think he needs
to preemptively pardon them.
Well, if Jared Kushner is being investigated
for being part of this shell company money
laundering scheme, that would be a great explanation.
It would fit very neatly into the puzzle of
why Donald Trump is reportedly considering
pardoning people like Jared Kushner and others.
Look at what we've been able to find out during
the Trump administration about what they've
done.
Imagine what will come out once this guy is
out of office.
Truly stunning
and remarkable.